allcoin market cap is on a cusp of a
historic moment it is retesting this
area as a new support this was a
resistance before but we've seen what
can happen when it is a support it
rallies to new highs and altcoin market
cap is positioned for that so we're
going to be talking about that in a lot
more detail this monthly chart as well
as well as many many altcoins into
today's video so subscribe to the
channel for more videos like this in the
future and like the video if you enjoy
content like this going forward and
let's dive right into it so this black
level right over here you can see that
this on the monthly time frame perfect
point of rejection into a bare Trend
right over here you can see that
retesting and retesting has enabled in
the past rallies to really great highs
and we've monthly closed above this
black level and so any pullbacks into
this black level that's going to be a
monthly retest before further highs and
the next level to reclaim is this 182
billion level we had this as a support
before so it will be very important to
reclaim this again because that would
enable a move into 300 billion which is
already almost 100% more than where we
currently are at so on the monthly time
frame we could potentially get a dip in
here it doesn't have to happen but any
dips would serve as fuel for the next
uptrend here we've been having fantastic
dips and retesting of this green region
as support so it really is well
positioned the altcoin market cap as a
whole and if we look at the monthly
closes on poka do for instance it's
broken this resistance it's broken out
from this macro Market structure it's
ready for a downtrend doesn't need to
retest the top of this pattern to
confirm the breakout fully and then
provide Trend continuation to this next
major resistance and of course this
major resistance here wouldn't reject
price too much we'd probably blast
through for it over time because this is
now a new Macro uptrend for
pkaa and fet fetch here has broken this
blue diagonal resistance of well really
just going back to 2022 so over a year
and a half we've just broken out Beyond
here and you can see here upside wicking
and then a rejection before here upside
wicking as well but a deeper rejection
so from a deep rejection to a shallower
rejection to now a monthly close Beyond
this previous point of resistance it
could turn into a new point of support
if we do dip that's going to be entirely
healthy before rallying towards the 60
Cent region once again we've already
been there but do we need a dip before
rallying to this red region of
resistance the last major resistance
before new or time highs for fetch a dip
would be healthy it doesn't have to
happen but if it does happen it will
serve as fuel for the next uptrend for
fetch going forward when you break a
macro downtrend that's been going on for
a year and a half we won't be seeing any
deeper retracements anytime soon unless
they're healthy dips in here injective
has managed to monthly close Above This
orange level retest it as a support and
we've got a fantastic monthly close
within this last range before injective
is able to break to new alltime highs so
we're currently just consolidating here
if we need a dip into the orange range
low that's going to be healthy once
again but generally speaking this final
major resistance point is the one to be
broken before price Discovery to new
alltime highs for injective we've broken
this monthly Macro downtrend for chain
link already we've broken Beyond it
doesn't look like we're going to retest
this region as a new support because
we're already finding a support in this
red region of old
resistance flipping it back into a
support like we saw right over here so
price stability at this region will
enable further upside in this new macro
down uptrend apologies any pull back
whether it's just downside wicking here
like we saw over here or even over here
any downside wicking or deeper pullbacks
would be constituting a retest right
over here but it might not occur because
of finding stability at this red region
of resistance which is turning into a
new area of Support over here for
polygon this monthly close occurred
below this macro downtrend but the thing
about that monthly close is that we're
now seeing price action Trend just
beside this Channel and now we might be
pulling back into the top of this
pattern to fully confirm the breakout
into a new macro uptrend after having a
downtrend dating back to 2022 so the
bare Market it's been almost more than
really just more than it's going to be 2
years now actually where polygon has
been has had this downtrend resisting
price and now it's ready for a new trend
and we're seeing the very beginnings of
these new trends so at the moment not
much upside but that will change with
time as price accelerates in its new
macro uptrend ocean protocol fantastic
monthly close into this red region of
old resistance and you can see here we
saw rejection from this resistance but
we blasted through it in 2021 held it as
a support despite some downside
volatility held it as support here as
well despite downside volatility here we
upside Wicked into this resistance but
now we're breaking Beyond it and if we
turn this region into a support then
we're going to ascend higher within this
current range of this red region of
support into the black level of 64 cents
but the main thing for ocean is to
challenge this macro downtrend this last
macro downtrend before it Revisited it
revisits this final resistance era
before new alltime highs we're probably
going to revisit this region this
downtrend over time and it will probably
break Beyond there as well maybe some
initial rejection but generally we're
going to break Beyond there and we'll
revisit this resistance era right over
here for a chance at breaking into price
Discovery for price and so this is
stacks and we saw a breakout from the
bare Market bottom here pull back for a
very long time into a falling wedge and
we've broken out here as well and this
is actually a play that I mentioned in
the rec Capital newsletter where we got
a fantastic reaccumulation channel here
and this was one of the first targets so
first target has been met and we got so
much more
74% from this reaccumulation range and
this is the next resistance here to
break beyond for STX generally speaking
Wave 1 then corrective wave wave two
then now a new wave three which could be
either the copy of
this wave 1 or it could be a bit more
even exuberant and then we'll have a
wave four before another wave five so
this is still going towards this major
resistance and there's still a bit more
upside left for STX seeing as it's
broken out from this falling wedge
enjoyed reaccumulation for a very long
time before now rallying once again
towards the upside and Theta token right
over here breaking out from its wedging
structure a macro wedging structure that
we haven't seen get broken since July of
2022 we've been rejecting rejecting and
rejecting here so many times over the
past year but now monthly close Beyond
this key resistance area and now Theta
to token might be soon pulling back into
the top of this region for a retest to
fully confirm this breakout into new
macro uptrend generally speaking this
dip doesn't even have to happen but if
it does we know what it's about it will
confirm the breakout and it would get us
closer to this
$133 region as the very first initial
Target because when price breaks out
from a macro downtrend that's been
lasting for as long as this one a new
macro uptrend tends to last a lot longer
or at least at the very least a similar
amount of time time we're now on the
cusp of a new bull trend for Theta and
many alt coins as we mentioned in
today's video so this if we need a dip
it's going to be a healthy dip before
further continuation to the
upside but that dip doesn't even
necessarily have to happen we can just
skip it and move higher anyway price and
many altcoins are now in a new macro
uptrend and so this bull market is going
to start enjoying its initial phases of
appreciation like we saw right over here
but there's still so much more to come
for many altcoins going forward and
that's about it subscribe to the channel
for more videos in the future like this
video if you enjoy this one and I'll
speak to you in the next one check out
the top right hand corner video for more
and I'll speak to you soon